on Saturday the co-founder of Twitter
apologized for his creation why because
it allowed the election of Donald Trump
in an interview with The New York Times
Evan Williams explained quote I think
the Internet is broken and it's a lot
more obvious to a lot of people that's
broken this is silliness of course the
internet isn't broken any more than guns
are broken just because bad people use
them sometimes to do bad things the
Internet is a tool that can do wonderful
good or great evil but Williams like
many of the left believes that if a
freedom can be exercised for great evil
it shouldn't be a freedom at all
thus he continues quote I felt once
everybody can speak freely and exchange
information ideas the world is
automatically going to be a better place
I was wrong about that it's a very bad
thing Twitter's role in electing Trump
if it's true that he wouldn't be
president if it weren't for Twitter then
yeah I'm sorry this is the problem with
leftist thought there many Americans who
are deeply unhappy at from selection but
there were just as many Americans
unhappy at President Obama's election
just because many Americans don't agree
with F Williams doesn't make a forum for
argument and discussion bad in fact
that's what should make the forum
important the shortcoming isn't Twitter
any more than the raucous debate that
surrounds politics thanks to the First
Amendment is responsible for excesses
performed by individual human beings we
simply do not have the right to control
what other people think or say even if
that results in bad people sometimes
winning victories we have the right to
argue them out of their position the
moment they move toward violence we have
the right to stop them but Twitter
didn't win the election for Trump it
just provided Trump a forum for
espousing his views which those on the
Left were unable to answer effectively I
don't believe all speech is created
equal some is evil some is valueless
some is great but I also don't believe I
have the right to be the sole
determinant of where those lines are
drawn and I certainly don't think that
tech executives who vote universally
Democrat have that right either on a
moral level when Williams compares
himself to Prometheus and says he
deserves to have Eagles quote peck out
his guts for eternity for giving the
power of tweets to Donald Trump he
forgets he didn't give the power of free
speech to Trump God did he just provided
a forum that wasn't moderated by someone
with which he agrees which is a good
thing perhaps you ought to help his
Democratic friends come up with better
arguments then shut Trump up if he wants
from Toulouse but Williams has another
solution restore the gatekeepers he says
the problem is that not everyone is
going to be cool because humans are
humans there's a lot better office door
in our homes in our at night the
internet was started without the
expectation that we'd have to do that
online except for the fact there's no
lock on our mouths nor should there be
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show
Oh President Trump went to Saudi Arabia
and great fun was had by all
he said some good things he said some
things that work and we'll talk about
all of it plus the imagery was just
amazing but first I want to say thank
you to our sponsors over at ring.com so
right now if you go to ring.com slash
pen get 150 dollars off a ring of
security kit so what that is an advanced
motion detection technology to protect
your entire property the kit includes a
ring video doorbell for the front door
we have that at my house what that is
someone rings the doorbell and usually
somebody's ringing or sometimes when
people are robbing your house they ring
to see if you are home first before they
rob the house the ring video doorbell
goes direct to your phone so you can
pick it up see who's at the door make
sure that they think that you're at home
or just make sure that it's somebody
that you know and like before you let
them in as well ring calm the video
doorbell does for you and they have a
ring stick up cam it's part of the ring
of security kit as well it's a wireless
weatherproof HD camera to keep an eye on
other parts of your property and right
now to go to ring.com slash pen you know
150 bucks off a ring of security kit we
have the kit we've bought extra gear
from ring because we think they are so
terrific in their product is so great
ring comm slash Ben right now join the
millions of homeowners who protect their
homes with the ring video doorbell again
it allows you to keep track of your
entire property make sure that nobody's
just ringing to break into your house
ring calm / Ben for a head 150 bucks off
your kit plus it allows them to know
that that were the ones who sent you so
that too helps them keep advertising and
paying so that the show can continue to
be brought to you for free okay so lots
going on
president Trump goes to Saudi Arabia so
it's great for Trump that he is now
doing this foreign tour because it's
obviously eating up all the headlines
that's something that he needs because
when last we left our story last
Thursday all of the talk was about Trump
and Russia and firing of Comey and the
Deputy Attorney General Rod Rosenstein
and there was a story that broke Friday
the Trump had said to the Russians and
the White House admitted that he said to
the Russians that he was happy he got of
Comey and he got rid of Comey because it
provided him relief on the Russia issue
which is not something that you've
probably be saying but the focus is now
shifted because Trump is abroad so as a
PR matter it's really good that Trump is
over in Saudi Arabia especially because
there's no proof that anybody's done
anything egregiously wrong as of yet and
all of the Trump Russia talk for the
MoMA
it is just that talk so Trump heads over
to Saudi Arabia and supposedly the point
of a tour like this is to create new
ties and re-establish old ties really
the point of a tour whenever a president
does a foreign tour the point of a tour
is generally the same as when you go
into the office at your work but you are
capable of working from home it's face
time okay so the point is not to
actually do anything useful it's to
demonstrate to people that you're active
it's to demonstrate to people that you
are on the move that things are
happening when Obama went on his apology
tour after he was elected that didn't
actually accomplish anything other than
sort of give off the image of America as
a country and retreat so Trump was going
to Saudi Arabia in order to change the
image of America as a country and
retreat some of that he accomplished
some of that he didn't but it started
off and and I do say I have to say it's
really funny when when Trump arrives in
Saudi Arabia the Saudis knew that he
loves pomp and circumstance and that he
loves flattery and flattery will get you
everywhere with Trump so they really
laid out the red carpet for him here's
what it looked like as Trump deep lanes
in Saudi Arabia just saw you let's go
see this
[Applause]
[Music]
almost exactly like that actually like
you see the guys dancing with the sword
so that actually happened in real life
this is so here is here's some video of
the Saudis doing the ceremonial sword
dance because nothing says friendly to
people like a ceremonial sword dance so
they all got out their swords into
surveillance and here is Trump be
bopping along to the ceremonial sword
dance that trim goes there he takes part
in all of this and of course everybody
on the left is saying well what in the
world this is a guy who's saying that
Saudi Arabia was in there's people
behind 9/11 and there is be bopping
along so the left is kind of
disappointed that Trump in started a
nuclear war the left is always
disappointed when Trump exceeds
expectations and their expectation is
that he was going to go to Saudi Arabia
spit on the Kaaba stone and then
immediately declare that everybody ought
to do to convert Christianity that is of
course not what happened and so they're
very disappointed that wasn't what
happened the imagery that came out
though was pretty weird because the the
great disconnect in American foreign
policy and this is existed well before
the Bush administration is it disconnect
where we say that we're against radical
Islamic error but then we make best
friends with the Saudis who fund radical
Islamic care so you have some weird
photos that were coming out like this
one this is the this is a 10 yeah yeah
this one so you got Trump with this is
the the I believe the king of Saudi
Arabia they're opening the global
anti-terror sensor which again if Saudi
Arabia's involved in the global
anti-terror center I'm going to go with
that's not going to be a huge success
and apparently Trump and the king of
Saudi Arabia is switching souls actually
or at least gazing into the Palantir to
see if they can see sour on or not the
problem is that that Hassan rouhani's on
the other end of that Palantir and can
actually see them Austin producer Austin
suggests that Donald Trump's basketball
skills were actually staffed by this
particular orb from space gem which is
indeed a possibility in any case but all
of this is you know not a huge deal you
the right made a queue
steal out of President Obama bowing to
the king of Saudi Arabia Trump didn't do
that the left it was really funny the
left tried to tell a fake news story or
Trump had bowed he wasn't bowing okay
the Prince of Saudi Arabia gave him some
sort of metal and he bent over to
receive it because the how else you get
it on the person's neck I mean it's like
saying that that Han Solo was bowing to
Princess Leia when she was awarding him
a medal after the destruction of the
Death Star no well it turns out that
whenever somebody puts a medal around
your neck you have to sort of lower your
neck so it can get around your neck so
the left immediately tried to suggest
that he was bowing in the same way that
Obama had bowed and that of course is
just ridiculous and silly towns and
nonsense I will again say that it was I
was a divided mind about about all the
pomp and circumstance surrounding Trump
arriving Ann Coulter said the reason in
Saudi Arabia welcome from ffice way is
because he's an alpha as opposed to
Obama who was a real beta here was an on
Saturday night so I like the fact that
you know because he is a strong alpha
male leader that that the air of his
respect them they don't respect the beta
male Obama okay well I think that
there's maybe some truth to this I think
that it's more likely that the the
Muslims figured that the Saudis figured
that if you flatter Trump a lot then he
will be nice to you and the reason I say
this is because that's exactly what Bibi
Netanyahu did immediately afterwards so
Bibi saw that they had rolled out this
red carpet they brought in they brought
in which country star wasn't they they
brought in some country music singer to
to sing in front of like an all-male
concert in Saudi Arabia they blew out
then they basically did the full Vegas
and Trump loved it and so immediately
Bibi Netanyahu recognizing the Trump
loves to be seated and treated like a
king be be immediately mandated that all
of his ministers had to be on the tarmac
when Trump went to Israel Trump arrived
in Israel today and Bibi mandated that
they basically upped the amount of pomp
and circumstance because now this is
turned into king we're a little bit
where King Lear wants all of the
daughters to show how much they love him
and just expressing the most glowing
terms how much they love him so all of
it is that a big deal or not
no in fact I think that it's kind of
great when countries pay homage to the
United States where the most powerful
country on earth as well we should be
but I'm not sure that the Saudis are
paying homage to the United States I
think they're paying homage to Trump
which is a slightly different thing ok
so then
Trump goes and he does his Saudi speech
and the speech itself you know
is widely praised by people on the right
I am of divided mind about the speech to
tell you the truth I think there are
some good things in the speech I think
there are some things that were not so
good in the speech I don't think it has
much to do with from I think that
Trump's speech has more to do with
divides in the mind in the mind of the
American people I think the American
people are very divided mind on foreign
policy and there not a clear mind on
foreign policy and there are three kind
of key distinctions in foreign policy
that the American people are not willing
to face up to because foreign policy is
filled with hard choices because anytime
you talk about a foreign policy in
reality what you're talking about is the
balance between diplomacy isolationism
involvement in the world military use of
force and these are very difficult
questions because no one wants to be the
person who puts American soldiers in
harm's way or expends American resources
in pursuit of some goal that we don't
care about and so there are three kind
of fundamental conflicts in American
foreign policy that have never been
resolved
particularly since world war two World
War two is the last time that all of
these were resolved in the United
fashion since then the United States
really has not had a coherent foreign
policy because World War two was such a
clear-cut moral battle and also such a
clear-cut battle of self-defense at the
same time there are some of the stirring
the Cold War as well this is the key
division between the right in the left
the right side is a mortal battle and a
self-defense battle the left sought as
neither self defense battle nor moral
battle and so there was battle over that
but here are sort of the three conflicts
in American foreign policy and you'll
see how they materialize in Trump's
speech so the first one is about human
rights so Americans have a very weird
perspective about human rights America
has always stood for the notion that all
human beings are created equal with
certain inalienable rights in our
Declaration of Independence that does
not mean however that it is the job of
the American government to achieve the
realization of those inalienable rights
for everyone America doesn't have the
power to do that America doesn't have
the wherewithal to do it if we could
snap our fingers and everybody would
have governments that protect the same
rights that we have then we would
obviously do that but it's not about
snapping the fingers it's about what are
you willing to sacrifice to do that so
the basic American foreign policy has
always been where possible we push we're
not possible we hold off but here's the
truth since Vietnam since the Vietnam
War we have very little interest as a
people then foreign interventions on the
basis of human rights until there's
something gross on our TV in which case
we get aggressive in
fashion which is sort of what happened
in Syria so we were like okay we don't
want anything to this area it's a civil
war it's going to get ugly fine who
cares and then there are pictures of
gasps children on TV and everybody snaps
- and boom we need to get involved right
now when you fire some cruise missiles
and hit a camel in the ass right now
it's incoherent but that incoherence
didn't start with Trump and it doesn't
end with Trump it's just incoherent
that's been part of American foreign
policy for the last few decades but then
incoherent means it is more incoherent
that means that they're basically a
couple of views on how to pursue human
rights people live themselves instead of
just saying listen we're not going to
save everyone we're not going to take
every human rights violation all that
seriously we're not we're going to take
the vacuum rights violation seriously
that we have to take seriously that in
that forward America's goals we're not
going to take other ones seriously
instead you end up with this sort of
bizarre snap back-and-forth foreign
policy so President Obama would speak
about human rights all the time but then
he felt that America was actually the
threat to human rights
so you'd withdraw from the region and
the isolationism and of setting the
region on fire
President Bush spoke about human rights
and he actually meant aids that meant he
was much more interventionist Trump is
actually more Obama than Bush not
because he thinks America is a bad force
in the world but just because he thinks
America should be isolationist and not
involved and so his foreign policy on
human rights is I'm going to speak in
strong terms about violation of Human
Rights but there's no actual carrot and
there's no actual stick and that's what
was missing from the Saudi speech
there's not a lot of carrot there's not
a lot of stick it was not clear what his
actual plan was in any of this and so
you have to ask okay well if he's not
laying forth the plan in saturated but
what's he there to do there's only two
things a foreign speech really is well
three things a foreign speech can do one
is it can rev up your domestic your
domestic base that's that I think did
and did well the second thing that it
could do is it could set forth a sort of
foreign policy goal I don't think that
Trump did that all that well and the
third thing is he could set forward
policy and he didn't do that at all
the second conflict so I said that there
are three central conflicts to American
foreign policy that Americans really
have not yet come to grips with because
it's ugly we don't actually want to make
these ugly choices I'm gonna get to the
second one in just a second but first I
want to say thank you to our sponsors
over at up side so I found this great
way to travel it's upside calm upside
calm is all about being able to travel
for cheaper as a business traveler it's
basically your yoga
this trip it's not only for families
more you travel a lot you have a
business trippin you get from point A to
point B upside calm bundles your flight
and your hotel and gets you the cheapest
possible price and they kick back to you
a gift card as well so they bundle that
flight and the hotel in a low price they
save money on business travel and then
they give you free Amazon gift cards so
if your company travels you a bunch of
times a year you get thousands of
dollars a year yourself just for buying
your air in your hotel through upsides
the price itself is lower than you'll
get anywhere else and then you also get
the kickback from amazon.com in terms of
the in terms of the gift cards as well
so you get all your miles you get a
lower price and that's all because of
the bundling they also have live
customer service so if you have a
problem you're not going to be stuck on
the phone with the Machine trying to
figure all of it out upside calm is the
best way to travel right now if you use
my name's you go to you go to up side
comm slash Bend and use that promo code
been radio listeners promo code been
then you are guaranteed to get at least
a $200 Amazon gift card for your first
trip so use them my name and it gets you
at least a $200 Amazon gift card for
free you say big on travel you get a big
gift card every single trip
I love up side comm we use here at the
office ourselves there's a minimum
purchase required you can see the site
for complete details but again you're
going to save money for your company and
you personally benefit which is pretty
awesome so go to up side calm and use
that promo code been not only so that
they know that we sent you but also you
can receive that $200 in gift cards with
minimum purchase on your very first
flight so that is pretty awesome okay so
I said there are three fundamental
contradictions in American foreign
policy one is over human rights we say
that we like them then we're not willing
to do all that much to to do anything
about them in many cases until there's
something ugly on our TV and then we do
something and this has been true since
Black Hawk Down in Somalia it's been
true in Yugoslavia it's been true in
Iraq it's been true in Syria it's been
true in Libya we have a tendency in the
United States where we don't actually
want to commit resources but then when
it comes down to it we recognize that we
are actually the world's policemen
whether we like it or not and that we
are sometimes going to have to commit
resources but there's no real good way
to articulate that fundamental conflict
number two over radical Islamic terror
so there's a lot of talk about how Obama
was doing in grave disservice to the
United States by not recognizing the
threat of radical Islamic care he
wouldn't even say the words radical
Islamic terror and the reason that Obama
said he wouldn't say the words radical
Islamic care is because his take what he
liked to say is that if he
two words radical Islamic terror he
would be lumping terrorists in with
regular Muslims and it has nothing to do
with Islam it's just a cult of death
that has nothing to do with Islam and
people on the right - no no no it does
have something to do with Islam and if
you fail to recognize that then you're
failing to look in the right place for
the enemy by pretending that Rivet
terrorism is equally a threat and Sweden
as it is coming from Saudi Arabia is
just silly it's just silly
and if you look at the polls you'll see
that a huge huge number hundreds of
millions of Muslims believe in things
that we in the West would consider
extraordinarily extreme I mean I have a
whole video about this about the myth of
the tiny radical Muslim minority and so
the whole point here was that leads you
to a long term strategy about how do you
change the Muslim world do you make
temporary alliances do you call on
Muslims to to do forward groups that are
more secular in nature in Muslim
countries but the point is that labeling
radical Islamic terror is connected to a
worldview and an action it's not just
about saying the words men doing nothing
and there is this fundamental disconnect
in the American mind because once you
recognize that hundreds of millions of
people are radicalized not terrorists
but radicalized and hold radical views
according to Western standards that
requires a pretty large sacrifice of
resources if you want to change that it
requires for example in some cases
regime change
it requires the backing of rebel groups
in particular areas that we might find
uncomfortable it requires us to get
deeply involved in areas that we don't
necessarily want to be involved in and
so we tend to do is we tend to say well
yeah we should label the bad guys the
radical Islamic terrorists but also it's
really not that many of them and they're
really not worshiping Islam so that's
sort of what happened with Trump
yesterday he said radical Islamic terror
and then he paired it a bunch of Obama
platitudes and finally the the third
conflict that exists in American foreign
policy that we really don't want to face
up to is the content is isolationism
itself so Americans tend to be gut-level
isolationist there has yet to be a
president who ran on being an
interventionist all presidents run on
being isolationist essentially and they
all end up interventionist because the
world is a pretty complex place so you
can either be honest about your foreign
policy or you can be not honest about
your foreign policy oh but President
Bush ended up he campaigned as an
isolationist hinter ended up as an
interventionist and stretched us too far
in the process
President Obama embraced isolationism
and watched the region burst into flame
the truth is that Trump is more along
Obama's lines in terms of withdrawal
from the region than his long Bush's
lines in terms of intervention in the
region and and so this speech was more
about like the right shot as a
fundamental rebuke to Obama and in some
ways it was the truth is it was actually
more of a fundamental rebuke to the Bush
foreign policy than to the Obama foreign
policy so now I actually want to play
some of the speech with all that in mind
actually want to go through some of the
speech but in order for us to actually
go through the speech you're going to
have to go over to Daily wire calm right
now and subscribe so for $8 a month you
can go over and subscribe it daily wire
calms you the rest of the show live with
our sparkling analysis each and every
day plus on Thursdays we do the mailbag
so you can be part of that there are
plenty of other goodies coming and if
you're an annual subscriber then right
now you still get a free copy of the
Arroyo a modern Western set on the
southern border about a rancher trying
to protect his lands from the
depredations of and depravity of the of
the Mexican drug cartels so go over and
subscribe become an annual subscriber
over at daily wire.com check that out or
if you just wanna listen later go over
to iTunes or SoundCloud become a
subscriber leave a review we always
appreciate your reviews make sure it's 5
stars or we don't want it but go over it
go for the iTunes or SoundCloud and make
sure you do that we are the largest
conservative podcast in the nation
[Music]
you